we have to firstly think about all those
families all those mortgage holders who
are going to be really struggling now in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
now their mortgage is going to go up as
well and they're paying the price they
are paying the price for 13 years of
economic failure under this government
we haven't had growth significantly for
13 years add to that the mini budget
last year which is huge damage to our
economy and the failure of the
government to do anything about energy
for years that would have kept our bills
down so now we've got the awful Prospect
of mortgage holders and families paying
the price of Tory failure